an echocardiogram is a common test using
sound waves to map out the shape and
size of your heart thus allowing your
doctor to see how well your heart pumps
blood and look for abnormalities of the
heart valves and chambers
in a transthoracic echocardiogram your
sonographer will put a cool gel on your
chest your sonographer will move a
transducer firmly through the gel
sending painless sound waves to your
heart the sound waves bounce off your
heart and echo back to the transducer
the sound waves are converted to moving
images of your heart muscles chambers
and valves on a video screen
a Doppler echocardiogram records echoes
from blood cells the speed and direction
of the blood flow indicate how well
blood gets around inside your heart
a stress echocardiogram evaluates images
of the heart before and after exercise
or following medication that simulates
exercise on the heart comparing your
echo results before and after activity
provides your doctor information about
certain heart problems such as coronary
artery disease that may only occur with
exertion a transesophageal
echocardiogram sends sound waves through
a transducer passed gently down your
throat while you're under sedation this
test provides a closer more detailed
evaluation of your heart